hello everyone Merry Christmas Happy
Fest AG season's greetings I'm back in
Bristol at my parents house which is why
the background looks so different
because of the season I'm here for a
couple of days to spend time with my
parents but whilst here recently I
finished a book and I want to talk about
it this book is of course a brief
history of time by Stephen Hawking and
I've got an interesting history with
this book those of you that don't know
this book is an incredibly famous
towering achievement in modern science
communication written by Stephen Hawking
so Hawking if you somehow don't know
this seriously poking was one of the
most brilliant physicists and most
remarkable stories of 20th century
physics I say most remarkable stories
because he did some incredible research
and you know he was a great scientist
and I say one of the greatest stories
because he overcame some remarkable
barriers to do his work notably for a
lot of his research career he was
paralyzed almost completely paralyzed
and unable to talk so doing his science
and writing a book are unbelievable
achievements and the book a brief
history of time is this is like a very
old edition that my parents had is a
sweeping panorama of where we're at in
terms of cosmology so that's the large
scale structure at the universe its
evolution and the physics which governs
it so of course a lot of discussion of
Einstein Ian's relativity a lot of
discussion of Newton but along the way
we're breezily introduced to pretty much
every major revolution in physics
history from quantum mechanics to Newton
Maxwell the whole shebang it is an
unbelievable work introducing you to
modern physics and I first read it when
I was 10 I'm sorry what yeah I first
read this this specific copy actually
when I was 10 years old in year 5 and
I've always been very dismissive at this
fact for a couple of reasons I basically
have always thought in the years since
then that I read the book is a way of
showing off I was like oh you guys are
reading His Dark Materials and Harry
Potter I'm reading the really good stuff
and in those years since reading it I
have basically assumed that my II didn't
take anything in I did it as a boast and
trying to show that I was somehow better
than the other kids in my class and that
I just didn't take anything on board I
was gonna have forgotten all of it so
when I picked it up recently as I said I
wouldn't the book
like a year ago I assumed that this
would be a completely fresh read for me
and that yeah there were a couple of
analogies that I vaguely remembered from
the first time around but this was all
gonna be new and then I opened the book
up where at the introduction and
everything came back to me for the
record I very much did I think read this
in year five as a boast I'm not arguing
with past Simon on that point but the
thing which astonished me was just how
much of this I took him in the sense
that I was getting a really weird
feeling of nostalgia that I felt like I
was ten years old again when I was being
introduced to some of these concepts in
this book like the introduction to
quantum mechanics so just before this
excerpt Hawking is talking about the
ultraviolet catastrophe this idea that
if a body radiates all three frequencies
equally when it's at a particular
temperature that it radiates an infinite
amount of energy which is obviously
ridiculous in order to avoid this
obviously ridiculous result the German
scientist Max Planck suggested in 1900
that light x-rays and other ways could
not be emitted at an arbitrary rate but
only in certain packets that he called
quanta moreover each quantum had a
certain amount of energy that was
greater the higher the frequency of the
waves so at a high enough frequency the
emission of a single quantum would
require more energy than was available
thus the radiation at high frequencies
would be reduced and so the rate at
which the body lost energy would be
finite that is such a tight tight
leeward an explanation of what quantum
mechanics is and where it came from and
reading it the second time I felt that
kind of rush of enthusiasm of oh my god
that's so simple but so cool but now
with the benefit of you know a physics
degree and the pH T it's it's like
attacking a piece of art first as a
child and having that sense of wonder
but then going back and maybe having an
art degree or years of you know
experience in the field going back and
looking at the same painting and you
feel a connection with your older self
but also a new appreciation of the work
and that was how I felt about this
entire book because in rereading it I
was able to look back at my younger self
and see this what made young Simon
interested in physics and it was it was
literally like a revelation that I
realized this book the brief history of
time was what made me go on to do a
physics degree it was what got me
interested in the physical world and
this
cramming it mathematically it was almost
like discovering a missing link that I
kind of just thought this this idea had
always been there I don't really have
any direct evidence there wasn't a
particular thing I could point to that
made me want to do a physics degree but
now I know what it is and I know it's
this so that's my personal kind of
connection to the book to give an actual
kind of book review it is quite slender
it's it's what like 170 pages of actual
content each chapter is a very neat kind
of sized digestible you can sit down
afterwards and sort of think about what
you've read I'm really keen to get pixel
girl my girlfriend who is a linguist to
read the first chapter at this because I
think it is the best introduction to
modern physics and explaining what
physics is how it works and vaguely what
the different subgroups of physics
behave like I can't think of anything
better as an introduction than the
introduction of this book admittedly I
am an atmospheric physicist by training
and Hawking was a cosmologists
so very different feels so when I was
rereading it there was a lot of stuff
which I had either forgotten from my
degree or I had just not really covered
because cosmologies it's quite a big
subject so there were a lot of nuggets
in here which I found particularly
interesting and you know excited my
childish curiosity again although this
was written in about perfer 1988 so 30
years on the research in this is going
to be a wee bit just just a wee bit out
of date and I think I'm gonna have to
pick up his latest book well his his
last book to get a more updated version
of the field so to me at least this was
full of new pieces of information
it was the connection to the childish
version of me so I loved it in that
sense but also it is just so slickly
written it's so easy to understand and
honestly that I think that probably the
best introduction to physics from a pop
science way of attacking the subject I
think this is in a way a companion piece
to six Easy Pieces by Richard Feynman
six Easy Pieces attacks the subject with
a little bit more maths to it this only
has I think equals mc-squared in it so
there's basically no math in this
whatsoever I think there's a certain
amount of pleasure taken in criticising
a book like this and I think that was
how I felt about it in the past couple
of years that it is just known as one
is absolute classics and you know it's
kind of cool in a way to hate on it in
the same way that people might be try
and be edgy by saying they that they
watch Star Wars I wasn't that good or I
don't know I listen to whatever it is
say the greatest piece of music ever
written
barks mass and B minor and they're like
yeah it was good I don't know but like
there are other better ones out there I
feel like I have been victim of doing
this with this book because I think the
past couple of years I have said to
people yeah it's a bit overrated it's
not that good but that was based on my
childish read of it and the fact that I
think I presented myself a little bit
for deciding to read it at a young age
for stupid reasons having come back as
an adult and read it I can say very
definitively this is a classic for a
reason it is a fantastic example of
science communication if you're a
physicist then you would do well to go
back and reread this and hopefully like
me rediscover that kind of spark that
got you into physics and if you're a
younger person watching this if you're a
student and you're thinking of maybe
doing physics University you want to see
what it's vague you like you should read
this maybe don't read this if you're 10
I I mean admittedly like I kind of did
well out of it but I wouldn't recommend
it to everyone now if you have a
different opinion if you think like I
did that this is overrated and there are
better ones out there I would very much
encourage you to comment below this
video and tell me what you think is the
best introduction to physics I'm kind of
putting six easy pieces and a brief
history of time together but if you
think there's a better one out there let
me know now to round off the video what
I've done a single book reviews before
in the book club I've always said what
I'm going to be reading next and we
tried to alternate between fiction and
nonfiction but I am reading outside the
book club now and so I'm actually gonna
cheat and put in another nonfiction book
but it's one that people have been
asking for for ages so if you'd like to
read along with me over the next six
weeks to two months I am going to be
reading homo Deus by Yuval Noah Harare
the sequel to the fantastically popular
sapiens which I have reviewed on this
channel in the book club I'm going to be
reading that and I would encourage you
to do the same because from what I hear
it's gonna be quite something so that's
what I'm going to be reading next you
can check out everything I'm reading by
the way on my Goodreads profile link in
the description along with links to this
book and to homo Deus which are full
disclosure affiliate links so if you buy
something from them I get a kickback
from it and hopefully you also get a
really good book
thank you very much for watching this
video do comment below if you have a
suggestion for what you think the best
introduction to physics is in book form
if it's not this or six easy pieces
thank you again for watching the video
pop it a like if you thought it was
interesting you can subscribe to this
channel for more mostly not book videos
but there will be book videos and share
it with people that you think might
enjoy it thank you for watching and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]